alison asked how do i pick the right  platform for my new business application  in the cloud  well alison i do it with this pyramid  first i start at the top can the new  application run on a low code platform  i happen to know google sheets and  google app sheet they let me whip up a  simple back office application in an  afternoon  but sometimes that's not enough for  example i may need a sql database or  greater scalability if so it's time for  serverless can the application be built  in cloud functions or as a container and  cloud run  if i need even more customization like  special hardware it's time for  kubernetes with google kubernetes engine  i can set up and manage a cluster of  machines with autopilot i even get auto  scaling  finally if that won't work it's time for  virtual machines i have to do a lot more  ops work but i can customize pretty much  everything  how do you pick a platform for new apps  let me know in the comments